[Music]
uncle duke is hanging out with the girls
in the treehouse
and it's the cutest thing
[Applause]
[Music]
they're all trying to eat
and tasks it's being
a good boy with his mom over there
so i was talking to
this lady and she was asking me
questions about my experience but at
this point i been loving what's been
happening when the moms raised the kids
they are super sweet and they are super
tame and they want human interaction
because we do take the time to go with
them
and spend time with them not only every
morning but every afternoon
so when i get them out the first thing
in the morning i sit down with them i
just climb all over me i pet them i get
all that energy out of them
and then by the time they're kind of
done with me they want to go explore
play in their tree house or something
like that then that is when i get my
clue i pick up my stuff and go
they spend most of the day with their
moms and playing around and trying to
pick up fights really with everyone in
the pen
at least the boy is
but when i come in the afternoon they
are kind of done with the herd and they
want that human attention again and so i
give it to them
we have a great time the girls like to
fall asleep on my lap or my daughter's
lap
it is the craziest thing that they
really enjoy spending time with us
but by six o'clock i've been putting
them in at seven
but by six o'clock they're kind of all
waiting by the gate so we go in and we
spend time with them
the little kids are kind of sleepy so
they do play but then at some point lay
down and they
they kind of let you know that they're
attire so we let them sleep on our laps
while we pet them and we wait for seven
o'clock and then
they all go in with our moms and their
pens
and you know they have as much milk as
they want at this point i'm not milking
i was milking but really it didn't work
as planned because i don't have a
separate area for milking and it was
stressful for the mom because the babies
wanted to nurse i had to clip the rest
of the coats duke was not having the
clipping and so once the boys move out
we'll be able to do something separate
and
we'll be able to get things done really
in there
i'm not worrying about
how much milk they're gonna produce i
see they have full udders
and even if they're not
amazing quantities of milk
i just need some grace at this time and
understand this is our first year with
goads
and we're doing the best that we can
so even though i don't have any
experience with bottle babies i think
that the experience that i have with our
moms raising them
it's
great really and
i don't think i would separate and
bottle feed in order to have a more
friendly goat maybe for other reasons
health reasons a mom rejecting her baby
but right now i this is my experience
and i thought i'd share it it might be
something that changes in the future but
right now
i really love
that they're okay with being with the
herd and they're okay being with us
and they're super sweet and super loved
you know they want your love
but at the same time it's not like i
have to babysit them 24 7.
[Music]
now if you know what that is let me know
what kind of bird is that
it's like it's coughing or something
anyways i hope that this was helpful
thank you so much for being here today
guys
if you're new please remember to
subscribe like the video and share if
you think it's helpful
i'll see you next time bye
[Music]